Sully mccutton is inconsolable after the
death of her 19 year old son he was on
board one of the several boats that made
it to Archer Indonesia a few days ago
but could not survive the ordeal
Muhammad no man's sister Aisha khatun
and her two daughters are among the
missing they were trying to reach
Malaysia in a boat with a dream to
reunite with her husband my sister with
her two daughters left camp on the 2nd
of December via technaf last time I
talked with my sister was on the 3rd of
December since then we have lost touch
with her we are now worried that the
boat carried my sister and nieces may
have sunk in the sea
nearly 1 million rohingya Muslims have
been living in Bangladesh refugee camps
since 2017 after fleeing persecution in
Myanmar Five Years on with no hope for
repatriation in sight most are desperate
to live
there's no livelihood for us here we are
in die poverty and there's no education
for the children which is why many are
fleeing the camp
facing increasing restriction and poor
living condition in the camps many
rohingya refugees are turning to
Smugglers willing to risk the dangerous
journey by sea to seek a better life
the U.N says 2022 could be one of the
deadliest years at Sea in almost a
decade for the rohingyas as growing
number flee desperate condition in
refugee camps
my parents are old and in bad Health
which is why my brother decided to leave
the camp and head to South East Asia
hoping to support the family we were
told that my brother jumped into the sea
out of desperation because he was
starving Bangladesh says it's trying to
stop rohingya refugees from risking
their lives in boats but with little
result Al jazeera's request for an
interview was declined by the Cox's
Bazaar police Bangladesh has been
generous hosts to the displaced
rohingyas but the International
Community has so far failed to put
pressure on Myanmar and the crisis
appears to be far from over tanvi
chaudry Al Jazeera Cox's Bazaar